choisir la politique du bouc émissaire
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
dangereux parce que c'est diviser sur
des bases en plus totalement
fallacieuses les vacciner les
non-vaccinés sachant que le virus
circulera peu importe le nombre de
vaccins on voit bien que les variants
arrive et omicron le montrent les
vaccinés sont d'ailleurs plus poreux
omicron que les autres on est vraiment
dans quelque chose de l'ordre de la
politique dégueulasse excusez moi du mot
mais après tout le président entend
merdé en choisissant de pointer du doigt
une minorité de la population française
et alors là poussant devant la foule en
disant voilà allez-y
c'est eux les responsables oui je pense
que vous exagérez un petit peu il n'y a
pas de lynchage pour l'instant de non
vaccinés par des vaccinés dans la rue il
ya en revanche oui les gens qui ne
subissent plus d'opérations qui devait
avoir à l'hôpital qui était prévu parce
qu'il ya des nourrissons nés qui
viennent prenant place donc là dessus
non parce qu'il y avait assez de place à
l'hôpital passer
sur 20 ans mais les montants je suis
d'accord avec vous sur la méthode
qu'utilise emmanuel macron qui est qu
est scandaleux surtout pour quelqu'un
qui se réclament du cercle de la raison
qui est censé être le leur pour pondérer
modéré à côté de tous les leaders
populistes qui l'entourent qui ne
peut faire des gens comme ça à qui
voudrait pas s'identifier et là ils
s'identifient sans doute parce qu'il est
en campagne électorale complètement voit
que ça fonctionne et qu'il a derrière
lui un électorat sûr et stable qui
veulent sortir de cette de cette
pandémie et ou qui ont peur de mourir et
ça ils ont tout à fait raison ou pas
mais ou pas peut-être qu'ils sont trop
trop trop glacée bien en tout cas vu
dans la méthode avec laquelle il ne fait
pas responsables